you
[Music]
dragon age inquisition zny lee announced
multiplayer looked an awful lot like
Mass Effect the reason multi player to
me so f it i'm gonna go back and take a
look Mass Effect 3 multiplayer it was
the thing that people got to the end of
the story campaign and went huh what's
this readiness rating in what to doing
to my single-player Galaxy at War thingy
well that my friend was mass effect 3's
multiplayer if you blink you may have
missed it but it greatly expanded on
single players combat systems and proved
that mass effect gameplay could stand
independent of a commander shepard
storyline here are five things Mass
Effect 4 can learn from what mass effect
3 multiplayer did really well number one
multiple playable protagonists there are
many ways to tell a story some of it
through dialogue and exposition some of
it through character and world design
Mass Effect 3's multiplayer leaned
heavily on the ladder and it did it in
ways that reinforced your connection
with characters and races from single
player this was a logical continuation
of the story campaign which already
featured side characters who are heroes
from their own epics and multiplayer you
could look at say a Krogan and know
exactly what you're going to get a
charging cynical tank beast
more subtly you could look at house a
Quarian marksman who's normally an
effective soldier was extra bananas when
it came to the get the quarians mortal
enemy likewise heavy and light melee
attacks were all factors of race and
class a Batarian wound up all day long
to land that homerun punch while the
guests juggernaut sucked the energy out
of foes this all indicates that mass
effect for could greatly benefit from
multiple playable protagonists number
two dynamic multiplayer maps combat
happens rain or shine oh wait it doesn't
in many multiplayer games okay Gears of
War spec ops the line and the last of us
have all flirted with the concept but no
one's really nailed it yet in the
glimpse we caught of mass effect for
development at e3 2014 we saw some
levels rendered with what appears to be
changing environments so I challenged
mass effect for to take it a step
further by ensuring gear powers and
situational awareness are all affected
by those changes Mass Effect 3
multiplayers rain and sandstorms made
levels not only more replayable but feel
more grounded in the universe number 3
co-op squad powers that work together
there's nothing quite like setting up an
enemy for a squad mate to biotic Lee
detonate
Mass Effect 3's multiplayer classes
worked well together complemented one
another and rewarded players for
directing abilities at the same target
the chorion marksman's tactical scan
ability could mark a target for
teammates in a game that didn't normally
have a spotting mechanic then debuff the
enemies speed and increased damage taken
to that target another example would be
popping an enemy off the ground with
shockwave and watching a team throw them
off the map these types of power combos
are a lot more fun than just say
outputting more damage with the marksmen
ability and they get individual players
working together in positive ways so
mass effect 4 should definitely build on
this complementary power system number
four rotating objectives killzone did it
and I don't know why everyone isn't
doing it many multiplayer shooters have
playlists but few have playlists that
rotate multiple times within a round
killing high-value targets hijacking
terminals escorting robots its variety
that keeps a game exciting and we'd like
to see more of that in Mass Effect 4 and
finally number five seamless co-op Mass
Effect 3 started with a good idea use
multiplayer co-op to help take and hold
territory that can affect the outcome of
the single-player campaign the formula
never quite worked largely due to the
co-op being is separate and independent
mode what mass effect 4 should do is
strive to put players together as often
as possible seamless co-op campaign
populating hubs like the Citadel maybe
PvP bounties the more human control
characters in the world the more that
world comes to life games like destiny
are already doing a great job at this
concept whether mass effect 4 ends up as
an expanded co-op encounter or an online
multi-player shooter player interaction
is where it's at well that's it for our
top 5 list did you spend any time in
Mass Effect 3's multiplayer getting your
whips on some people in our office never
even touched it did you go fill out
Bioware survey on what you want the next
Mass Effect to be leave your thoughts in
the comments below and hey fire up the
old massive entry multi-player you might
find yourself shoulder to shoulder with
a smelly Batarian and loving it